all eyes will be on Riri at halftime but
during the big game it's brother versus
brother for Travis and Jason Kelsey Mom
Donna who is partnering with Sleep
Number won't be losing sleep over which
team to cheer for somebody's gonna win
somebody's gonna lose who do you go to
first I definitely want to go down and
celebrate with the person that's holding
the trophy but I will go back to the
team hotels and I'll give them a hug
tell them I love them there is nothing I
can say that will make him feel any
better which one is your favorite you
know each one has been my favorite at
certain times in in their in their lives
uh right now Jason's a little ahead
because of the grandchildren but I'm
sure Travis will take it over soon
better dancer
well Travis will dance all the time
Jason needs a few beers but when he
dances it's a spectacle
really everybody will remember it when
they see it
one parenting regret having to watch
Travis's reality dating show just
couldn't watch the kissing I would like
speed through it it's hard to watch your
kid doing that
foreign